اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم عبد القادر
عياد في الوقت الذي يحدث فيه تقع واحداث
وتتفاعل اخرى في مناطق مختلفه من العالم
اليوم السابعه عشر من كاس العالم في قطر
2022 تميزوا بتاهل المغرب لدور الثمانيه
للمره الاولى في تاريخ مساره الرياضي هذه
الصور من الرباط على الاحتفالات الجماهير
المغربيه بهذا الانجاز الكبير
وفي سوق واقف بقلبي الدوحه تواصل جماهير
المنتخب المغربي احتفالاتها بفوزه الى
الدور الربع النهائي على حساب اسبانيا
اما فيواجه منتخب البرتغال نظيره السويسري
لانتزاعي بطاقه التاهل الاخيره الى دور
الثمانيه النتيجه حتى الان هدفاني
للبرتغال دون مقابل وفي مواضع الحصاد هذه
الليله
مواقع بتعرف بقوه سوريا الديمقراطيه شمال
شرق سوريا في مرمى قصف المدفعيه التركيه
اردوغان يتمسك بمحاربه بالارهاب ومنع
وصوله الى تركيا ومصدر تركيا
مهله اخيره من انقره لموسكو واشنطن اما
اخراج قوه سوريا الديمقراطيه او عمليه
عسكريه بريه
الجيش الاوكراني يقول ان روسيا قصفت
بالمدفعيه اكثر من 20 بلده اوكرانيه
روسيا تتهم اوكرانيا بتكثيف هجمات
بالمسيرات على مطارات داخل اراضيها الكريم
الذي يقول ان قتل راس اجتماعا لمناقشه
كيفيه ضمان الامن الداخلي للدوله
والخارجيه الامريكيه تكشف عن مخزون الكاف
من الاسلحه لدعم اوكرانيا
بعد اجراء طريقها القانوني تحقيقا كشف عن
ادله جديده شبكه الجزيره الاعلاميه تعلن
رفع قضيه اغتيال الزبيل شيء ابو عاقله من
قبل قوات الاسرائيليه امام المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه وتقول ان الادله اظهرت
تعرض شيرين وزملائها لاطلاق نار مباشر
ولبيب يقول انه لن يتم
من جنوده
في لقائنا اليوميه على الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه كنا قد ناقشنا معكم رفع شبكه
الجزيره الاعلاميه قضيه اغتيال زميله
شيرين ابو عاقله برصاصيه الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي الى المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
في لاهاي وقالت الشبكه ان ذلك ياتي بعد
اجراء فريقها القانوني تحقيقا كشف عن ادله
جديده تظهر بوضوح ان شيرين وزملائها
تعرضوا لاطلاق نار مباشر من قوات الاحتلال
ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا
عليكم السؤال الثاني برايكم ما بدا تاثير
رفع شبكه الجزيره موضوع اغتيال الزميله
شيرين ابو عاقله الى محكمه الجنايات
الدوليه في مسار القضيه
45% توقعوا ان يكون له تاثير كبير بينما
قال
55% ان التاثيره سيكون محدودا
هذا سؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصه الرقميه
يمكنكم الدخول صفحه التصويت عبر مسح رمز
كيو ار الظاهر على الشاشه
لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا ودوليا
وبعد الحصاد مباشره وتحديدا في الساعه 12
و 5 دقائق بتوقيت مكه المكرمه تتابعون
الجوله الرياضيه اليوميه يوميات المونديال
التي ترصد بالخبر والتحليل مباريات كاس
العالم قطر 2002 2020
افاده مصدر تركي رسمي للجزيره ان تركيا
اعطت مهله زمنيه محدده للجانبين الامريكي
والروسي لاخراج قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه من
منبج وتل رفعت وعين العرب وقال المصدر ان
انقره ابلغت الجانبين الروسي والامريكي ان
المهله لن تمدد وان البديل سيكون عمليه
بريه ضد القوات الكرديه في غضون ذلك قال
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان ان لدى
بلاده القدره على تحقيق انتصارات لا يتوقع
احد عندما يتعلق الامر باي تهديد ضد
وجودها
في شمال السوري تفرقت المصالح وتضاربت
الاجندات بين تركيا وروسيا والولايات
المتحده فامام المعارضه الروسيه
والامريكيه لعمليه باليه تركيه عالمه
الجزيره من مصدر رسمي تركي ان انقره وضعت
شروطا وحددت مهله للامريكيين والروس من
اجل ان تتراجع عن الحمله البريه الموعوده
حدد تركيا شروطها في اخراج ما تعرف بقوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه من منبج وتل رفعت وعين
العرب كوباني شمال سوريا وانهاء سيطرت هذه
القوه على المنشات النفطيه وذلك قبل النظر
في المقترحات الامريكيه لانقره
ومقترحاته واشنطن يتعلق باعاده هيكله ما
تعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه بمنح دور
اكبر للمكون العربي في اداره منبج وتل
رفعت وعين العرب كوباني على الجانب الاخر
قدم روسيا عرضها ووضعت شروطها فقد عرضت
رفع الغطاء عن منطقه الشهباء في ريف حلب
وعين العرب لتسهيل دخول القوات التركيه
اليه
اما شروطها فقال المصدر التركي انها تتعلق
بتنازلات في الملف الاوكراني ماذا ان لم
تتحقق الشروط وتجاوز الزمن المهله التركيه
المصدر الرسمي التركي ابلغ الجزيره ان
البديل سيكون تنفيذ العمليه العسكريه
البريه التي تعد لها انقره تاكيدا لذلك
قال رئيس التركي ان بلاده ستنهي ما وصفه
بالارهاب في شمال سوريا وانها قادره على
تحقيق انتصارات لا يتوقعها احد تركي سترل
المجادله بخصوص كفاح هذه الارهاب على
انهائه اينما كان اذا كان في سوريا فنحن
لن ندفعه للذهاب الى داخلها بل سننهيه في
شمالها يخرج لبعض الالي يقول لنا لا
يمكنكم القيام بهذا وذاك في كوباني لم يعد
هناك شيء اسمه كوباني انتهت ومن قال انه
لا يمكننا القيام باي شيء هناك
يبدو بذلك عامل الزمن محدودا امام المساعد
دبلوماسيه الروسيه والامريكيه ثمت على
الارض ما يؤكد مديه تركيا قدما في
الاستعداد للعمل العسكري البري مع استمرار
عمليات القصف بالمدفعيه والطائرات المسيره
فقد قصف الجيش التركي تجمعات ومراكز لما
تعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه في قرن
بمحيطه الابيض بريف الرقه وعين العرب في
ريف حلب على الحدود مع تركيا اضافه الى
ريف الحسكه
طلبوا انقر من واشنطن ابعاد ما يعرف بقوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه عن المنشات النفطيه
يعيد تسليط الضوء على الموارد الاقتصاديه
المهمه التي توجد في مناطق سيطره تلك
القوه تتعرف على ابرز تلك الموارد في
العرض التالي
في شرق وشمال الشرقي سوريا حيث تسيطر ما
يعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه تتركز معظم
ثروتي النفط والغازي في سوريا واستنادا
الى تقرير لوزاره النفط التابعه للنظام
السوري في اغسطس هذا الماضي فن القوات
الامريكيه وما يعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه تستوليا يوميا على 66,000
برميل منطقه الشرقيه في حين ان لا ارقام
دقيقه عن حجم الانتاج الفعلي لتلك الحقول
تصدر عن المسلحين الاكراد سيطرت ما يعرف
بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه على تلك المنشات
الحيويه بعد معاركها مع مسلح تنظيم الدوله
خلال عام 2017 و 28
وتقيم القوات الامريكيه قواعد لها في بعض
تلك المنشات
النفطيان بريف دير الزور هما من اكبر حقول
النفط في سوريا كما توجد ابار النفطيه
صغيره في الرقه اما في محافظه الحسكه توجد
بها حقول الرميلان والجرسه والهول اضافه
الى عشرات الابار النفطيه كما توجد في نفس
مناطق سيطره ما يعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه حقول ضخمه للغاز ابرزها منشات
كونكو دير الزور وهي اكبر حقل الغاز في
سوريا اضافه الى حقل الشبسه والسويديه
بريف الحسكه
معنا من انقره ايضا نورهان السفير السابق
في الخارجيه التركيه ومن يورك العقيده
الثالث المتحدث السابق باسم التحالف
الدولي لهزيمه التنظيم الدوله في العراق
وسوريا اهلا
بالضيفيه ارضى معك العقيد همم
كيف وجدت هذا القرار التركي مغلق ان لم
يتم التجاوب مع المطالب التركيه ستقوم
بعمليات بريه وماذا عن هذه المناطق التي
حدثتها تركيا لاخراج ما تعرف بقوه سوريا
الديمقراطيه منها
صباح الخير صباح الخير كيقول القصد له
مساء الخير هذه مناقشات تجربه بين تركيا
وروسيا وهي استمرار مهم
لماتوره الاتفاق عليه ما بين هاتين
الدولتين في سوشي في اكتوبر 2019
في ذلك
وان العالم
ينبغي ان يفعل كل ما في وصفه
لمحافظه والابقاع على السلام في هذه
المنطقه دعني ابقى معك العقيد مايرز و اقف
معك عندما قلت بان المؤشر الجديد وصفته
بالتصرف العدائي من قبل الجانب التركي هل
تجده كذلك تصرفا عدائيا
ننظر الى ما يحصل عندما تقول تركيا بان
سيقومون بغزوه بريه او هجوم من بريه هم
يقولوا سيره الرسول
القوات التركيه
فعلا موجودين الان في عفرين والناس في
عفرين نقل او يخرجوا من منازل لهم
ومزارع الزيتون في عفرين قطعت اشجارها
والان هناك مجموعات ارهابيه في عفرين ان
تركيا تريد تكرارها في منبج
انت عاوز ايه عام 2019 عندما قامت تركيا
وروسيا بالاتفاق على منطقه امنه بين راس
العين
وتل ابيض
المنطقه التان الان فيها
مجموعات ارهابيه تدعمها تركيا وبالتالي
فان تركيا
بين تركيا وبين روسيا هل معنى ذلك بان
واشنطن ليست معنيه بهذا القرار التركي
بس همم
يو 9
وان الدوري الامريكي في شمال وشرق سوريا
يركز على مهمه مكافحه تنظيم الدوله ولكن
عندما عندما تكون قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
اقوى حمايه الشعب
بالتعرض لخطر من قبل تركيا سيؤثر على كل
محمد مكافحه تنظيم الدوله
وحددت هذه الاماكن ووجهت الرساله للطرفين
الروسي
والامريكي ماذا عن هذه المهله وعن هذا
القرار التركي
اه كب كيك
نحن نريد
سوريا واحده لا نريد
استقلال او حكم ذاتي لحزب العمال كردستاني
في سوريا
في تركيا كما لديهم العديد
لبنان الدول اخرى اذا عندما يعود هؤلاء
الى سوريا
يبدا توم وجيري
وعندما تاتي الديمقراطيه فان هذه الخمسه
من السكان سوريا في تلك المنطقه
الديمقراطيه
ماذا يكون هدفها النهائي
هل تريدون التقصير سوريا هل تريدنا اعطاء
الثلث اراضي سوريا لخمسه بالمئه من
المواطنين واعطائهم الحكم الذاتي او
الاستقلال كلا هذا السخيف هذا غير منطقي
طيب
قبل التحقيق السلعه ما تريده تركيا وفي
نهايه النطاف وكانت قد وافقوا قد امريكا
على ذلك
ان هناك عذاب من 30 كلم ل ل داخل سوريا
هذه منطقه غزوها هذه هذه نقطه مهمه حضرتك
للموقف الامريكي قرار تركيا باللجوء الى
هذه الخطوه هل معنى ذلك ان التشاور مع
الطرف الامريكي قد بقى بالفشل
الولايات المتحده
للجيش
الجيشين بالوكاله
نحن نريد اقناع الولايات المتحده
لثلث
رغبتهم تاريخيه بالنسبه لروسيا هي ان يصل
الى المياه
في سوريا حاليا هذه هذا عنصر اخر ولكن
الولايات المتحده
النيه الاساسيه كما نعلف في تركيا
الى البحر الابيض المتوسط كما ورد ان اقول
لكم
80% من الاتراك
لا يحبون امريكا
فكيف حصل ذلك
الشكر لضيفي من نيويورك العقيده
الثالثه المتحدث السابق باسم التحالف
الدولي لهزيمه تنظيم الدوله في العراق
وسوريا شكرا جزيلا لكم
في اخر التطورات الميدانيه لحرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا في مقاطع تحديدا قالت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه ان قواتها دمرت ثلاثه
مستودعات صواريخ وذخيره للقوات الاوكرانيه
من جهتها قالت رضع المواليه لروسيا ان قصف
اوكرانيا استهدف صباح اليوم المنطقه
الصناعيه التابعه
للطاقه النوويه
تعرض احد مصانع الكيماويات لقصف المدفعي
الاوكراني دون تسجيل اصابات وبالانتقال
الى البحر الاسود قالت قياده العمليات
الجنوبيه الاوكرانيه ان قواتها رصدت
تحركات ل 15 سفينه روسيه بينها حاملتها
صواريخ في السياق نفسه قالت قياده القوات
الجويه الاوكرانيه ان مناطق كيا وخيرسون
وزباروجيا وميكو لايف تعرضت لقصف الروسي
بوابل من الصواريخ من البحر الاسود وبحر
قزوين
استهدف قصف الاوكراني وسط مدينه دونياس
كانت تسيطر عليها القوات الروسيه لها في
شرق اوكرانيا واستهدف القصف سوقا تجاريا
وكنيسه اضافه الى مستودعات تجاريه قريبه
من محطه للكهرباء في المدينه مراسله
الجزيره سلام خضر والتفاصيل
الذي يبدو خلفي وتندلع منه
استهدي فقط
صواريخ اوكرانيه فرق الاطفاء تحاول السيطر
على الحريق وتحاول فرق الاسعاف ايضا
الدخول
لانقاذ المحاصرين حتى الان لا نعرف ان كان
هناك اعداد كبيره من المواطنين داخل هذا
السوق ولكن فرق الاطفاء تعمل حاليا على
السيطره على النيران هذا احد الشوارع
الاساسيه
السلطات المحليه هنا تقول ان المدينه ومنذ
نحو اسبوع تتعرض لما تصفه السلطات هنا
بانه الاستهداف الاعنف والاكثر كثافه منذ
بدء الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا او ما
تسميها موسكو العمليه العسكريه الخاصه الى
جانب هذا السوق هنا احدى ترائيات سقط
عليها ايضا صاروخ من ضمن مجموعه صواريخ
التي اطلقت قبل قليل على دنياسك حتى الان
همم لا نعرف ان كان احد قد اصيب داخل هذه
الكنيسه سلام خضر الجزيره من وسط مدينه
دنياز
الذي عقد بين رئيس المجلس الاوروبي ورئيسه
المفوضيه الاوروبيه ورئيس وزراء المانيا
ان تصعيد روسيا ضد اوكرانيا يعرض الامن
الاوروبيه والعالميه بالقطر
لا مسار جديه للتسويه حتى الان يكبح مسار
الحرب في اوكرانيا غير ان المنابر
السياسيه في العواصم المنخرطه في ذلك
النزاع بشكل او باخر لا تخلو من حديث شبه
يوميا عن السلام في موسكو اعلن المتحدث
باسم الكرملين ان روسيا تتفق مع الولايات
المتحده بشان الحاجه الى اقرار سلام دائم
في اوكرانيا لكنها لا ترى في الوقت الراهن
فرصه لاجراء مفاوضات
واكد المتحدث ضروره تحقيق بلاده اهداف
عمليتها العسكريه الخاصه قبل اجراء اي
محادثات
اوكرانيا ايضا تبدو معنيه بالسلام لكن فقط
كما تراه هي ان يغادر الجيش الروسي
اراضيها طواعيه او بالقوه
والاصعب والاقصى ونعرف ان الثمن غال ولكن
هدفنا هو تحرير ارضنا وحمايه بلدنا اعتقد
اننا سنلتقي في المرات المقبله في دنياك
الاوكرانيه
وشبه جزيره الكرم المحرره
خطاب تعبوي للداخل تزامنا مع رسائله
تحملها المسيارات مفادها ان اوكرانيا باتت
قادره على ايلام روسيا داخل اراضيها بعد
استهداف مطارات روسيه
تبدو هذه معادله جديده وهي مثل ما تؤجج
الحرب يمكنها لاحقا التاثير ايجابا على
مجريات الاحداث وتفكير صناع القرار
العسكريين والسياسيين احاديث التسويه
وسلام تردد صداها ايضا في تيران عاصمه
البانيا حيث يعقد قاده دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي قمه مع نظرائهم في دول غرب
البلقان السته قبل ذلك اكد مسؤول السياسه
الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي ان حل
النزاع يتطلب تقديم ضمانات امنيه
لاوكرانيا اولا ولروسيا لاحقا
وفي الولايات المتحده توقع وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي انتهاء الصراع في اوكرانيا
بالطرق الدبلوماسيه
داعياف الى تحديد النطاق المستقبلي للحرب
وشروط انهائها
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي ان لدى الولايات
المتحده مخزونه اسلحه كافيه للاستمرار في
مساعده اوكرانيا واضافت جيرمان خلال
مشاركتها في ندوه بجامعه لويس في ايطاليا
ان ان اسرع طريق للسلام في اوكرانيا هو ان
تسحب روسيا كن قوتها واشارت الى ان الدعم
الغربي لاوكرانيا نجح في مقاومه الغزو
الروسي وفق تعبيرها مؤكده ضروره استمرار
هذا الدعم
لاحقا نعود الى حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
ونركز مع ضيفنا على زاويه المخاوف التي
احيتها هذه الحرب من اللجوء الى السلاح
النووي
رفعت شبكه الجزيره الاعلاميه قضيه اغتيال
زميله شيرين ابو عاقله برصاصه قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي الى المحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه
تاتي بعد اجراء فريقها القانوني تحقيقا
كشف عن ادله جديده تظهر بوضوح انا شيرين
وزملائها تعرضوا لاطلاق نار مباشر من قبل
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
هي خطوات النحو عداله طال انتظارها سته
اشهر مضت ولا يزال قاتل شيرين ابو عقله
حرا في مقر المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه تقدم
شبكه الجزيره ملف للدعاء الى المحكمه خطوه
يراد منها الضغط على اسرائيل لتقديم
الجناه امام العداله
عن شبكه الجزيره الاعلاميه ملف الادله
الكامل الى المدعي العام في المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه على المحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه تحديد الافراد الضالعين بشكل
مباشر في قتل شيرين
والمحكمه الجنائيه لها صلاحيه كامله للنظر
في هذه القضيه ليس فقط لمحاسبه المسؤولين
المباشرين فالايضا من تقاعسو عن منع
حدوثها
ويعد تقديم الملف خطوه عمليه في اتجاه فتح
تحقيق رسمي من قبل مكتب المدعي العام
للمحكمه وتاتي هذه الخطوه بعد ان فتحت
المحكمه في وقت سابق تحقيقا في ما يحدث في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه
وينتظر ان تضم قضيه شيرين ابو عقل اليه
كثيره قدمها شهود عيان وعشرات التحقيقات
التي اجرتها وسائل الاعلام ومنظمات حقوقيه
والامم المتحده تشير الى استهداف شيرين
وقتلها من جندي اسرائيلي مع ذلك لا تعرف
من هو الشخص الذي اطلق الرصاصه القاتله
ومن هو المعني في سلسله القياده
تعال تعال
استغرق التجهيز الملف المقدم اربعه اشهر
يضم الملف 27 صفحه مكتوبه
استمع فريق الجزيره القانوني الى شهادات
10 اشخاص كانوا في موقع الجريمه
يضم الملف ادله مصوره من قبل الفريق
وملفات فيديو قتلت شيرين على يد جندي
اسرائيلي في شهر مايو من العام الجاري في
مخيم جنين ومنذ حينها تماطل اسرائيل في
الاعتراف بالجريمه
وبالمسؤولين عنها
ورغم عدم توقيع اسرائيل على ميثاق المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه الا انه وقوع الجريمه
على اراد فلسطينيه يجعل المتهمين خاضعين
لسلطه المحكمه هي معركه نفس طويل اذن
السعي وراء الحقيقه والحد من سياسه
الافلات من العقاب على اعتاب مرحله جديده
يقف ملف اغتيال شيرين ابو عقله بعد ان
اصبح في يد القضاء مرحله عنوانها الابراج
الكشف عن الحقيقه ولا شيئا غير الحقيقه
عبد شامي الجزيره لا هاي
في ضوء هذا التطور ما هي الخطوات المتوقعه
من المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه بعد تسلمها
لملف قضيه اغتيال الزميله شيرين ابو عقله
متابع التغيرات التاليه
بعد تسلم المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه لملف
اي قضيه يقوم المدعي العام للمحكمه بتقيمه
والتاكد من وجود اساس للدعوه وبان الجريمه
المنظوره تقع ضمن اختصاص المحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه ثم يقوموا بتحليل متى واين ومن قد
يكون ارتكب الجريمه ثم يقرر لاحقا البدئه
او عدم البدء بالتحقيق خلال هذه المرحله
تقوم المحكمه بارسال الملف القضيه وما
يحتويه من ادله وشهدات الى الطرف المدعه
عليه وهو هنا في قضيه اغتيال زميلات شيرين
ابو عقله الجيش الاسرائيلي لسماع تعليقه
ورده على ملف القضيه والبيانات المرفقه
فيه في حال قرر المدعي العام فتح تحقيق
بالقضيه فانه سيقوم بتوجيه الابتهامه
للجناء وهم في هذه الحاله الجندي الذي
اطلق النار على زميله راحله شيرين ومن
اعطاه الامر بذلك بعد ذلك ستطالب المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه اسرائيل بتسليمها
المتهمين لمحاكمتهم وفي حال رفضت اسرائيل
ذلك يمكن للمحكمه ان تحاكمهم غيابيا في
حال ادانه المتهمين في القضيه ستقوم
المحكمه بالتعميم عليهم عند كل الدول
الموقعه على اتفاق روما الذي انشات
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه بموجبه وستكون
تلك الدول ملزمه بالقاء القبض عليهم في
حال دخلوا اراضيها وتسليمهم الى المحكمه
في لهاي تبقى اوامر الاعتقال بحق المتهمين
نافذه مدى الحياه ما لم يقرر قضاه المحكمه
لاحقا خلاف ذلك
اما جاء في هذا التقرير زميل احمد جرار
نسال ضيفنا من لاهاي الدكتور جون دوغارد
استاذ القانون الدولي والمبعوث الاممي
السابق لحقوقيه الانسان في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه اهلا ذكر دكتور دوغارد
على اي اساس تشرع محكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
في السير في مسارها القانوني بناء على
الملف الذي قدم من شبكه الجزيره
من اهم خطوه اولى وهي
ان المحكمه الدوليه لديها صلاحيه
لمحاكمه اجرائم المرتكبه في الدوله الطرف
المحكمه وفلسطين هي فعلا دوله عضو في
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه وبالتالي
للمحكمه صلاحيه قانونيه لدراسه النظر في
هذا الموضوع
وكما الجنائيه
فلسطين منذ سنوات عديده وان قضيه شيرين
حيله الى المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
السابقه من قبل دوله فلسطين ومن قبل خارب
لها ومن الواضح جدا هو المهم ان الجزيره
قناه الجزيره يكون لها صوت ايضا لضاف الى
هذه شكاوى السابقه ومن الواضح ان قناه
الجزيره قد اكتشفت ادله جديده مما يوضح
بان عمليه طلاق النار كانت مقصوده وليست
عن طريق الخطا وبالتالي اعتقد انك
بالتاكيد قضيه قانونيه
لابد ان تسمعها قبل الحكومه الاسرائيليه
وليس فقط الشخص الذي اطلقه الرصاصه
بالاضافه المسؤول عنهم قد ايضا يحاسب لان
يكون من الصعب جدا
همم كل من المطلق النار هو خاصه
الذي امر بالقتل ولكن الصعوبه تكمن انه ان
تكون هناك ضغوط سياسيه على مكتبه
الدوليه لعدم اتخاذ اجراءات ضد اسرائيل
وهنا تكون المشكله التي نواجهها فيما
يتعلق
التقديم فيما يتعلم موضوع موضوع فلسطين
امام المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه من نريد
انك ارسلت الى ان همم هي عضو في محكمه
الجنايات الدوليه رئيسا الوزاره
الاسرائيلي يقول بانه لن يسلم اي جندي
اسرائيلي وبالتالي ماذا عن مسار التحقيق
في حال عدم تعاون الطرف الاسرائيلي في هذه
الشكوى المقدمه
من الواضح جدا ان اسرائيل لن تتعاون مع
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه ولكن ايضا هناك
دائما امكانيه ان الذي اطلق النار
او اي شخص لابد انه قد سافر الى الخارج
وبالتالي يمكن اعتقاله اذا ما سافر الى
الخارج ثم يقدم جنائيه الدوليه ولكن
بالتاكيد اسرائيل ستقام وترفض كل الجهود
المقررات جنودها من قبل المحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه وعليا تذكر انه الولايات المتحده
ستدعم اسرائيل تماما كما تستفعل بعض الدول
الاوروبيه
استاذ القانون الدولي السابق لحقوق
الانسان في الاراضي الفلسطينيه شكرا جزيلا
لك
اصدرت المحكمه الاسرائيليه المركزيه
لمده عشر سنوات على الشاب ادهم بشير من
مدينه عكا داخل الخط الاخضر وذلك بتهمه
المشاركه في احداث الهبه الشعبيه التي
اندلعت في مايو في ايار مايو من العام
الماضي احتجاجا على العدوان الاسرائيلي
على القدس و غزه وكانت المحكمه قد اصدرت
قبل فتره قصيره احكاما بالسجن الفعلي مده
خمس سنوات وسبع سنوات على شابين من مدينه
تمره شمال مدينه حيفا بتهمه المشاركه في
الاحتجاجات
حقيبه صغيره لمده طويله هكذا يبدو حزم
الامتعه للسجن اتهم ادهم بالقاء حجاره
خلال احتجاجات هبت ايار العام الماضي وقضت
محكمه الاسرائيليه بسجنه 10 سنوات
حجر يعني
القرار يغادر ادهم الى مرحله ستغير مسار
حياته
عندما تخلي السجن انتظره بعض الاصدقاء
والداعمين وحتى اخر لحظه ظلت والدته تنتظر
ان يتبدل الكابوس كما تقول
عمري راحت
وافرح حتى لو طلع خلاص يعني عشر سنين من
عمره هذول اغلى شيء انا بحياتي مش هونين
بين المساندين وقفت والده محمد وقد عاشت
هذه اللحظات قبل مده قصيره عندما صدر
الحكم على ابنها بالسجن سبع سنوات عقب
انتزاع اعتراف منه بما لم يقم بفعله قالوا
له انه امك ماتت اعترف عشان تطلع تحضر
الجنازه ولد عمره 18 سنه
تعرف بهبه الكرامه اقدم اسرائيلي على دهس
مجموعه من الشبان الفلسطينيين في مدينه
عكا فقبل بالحجاره
كان ادهم حينها في الموقع قريبا من بيته
ومنذ اذن لم يرن نور
كان وقع الاحكام صادما على عشرات الشبان
ممن ينتظرون احكامهم بتهم مماثله لا سيما
ان المحكمه اصدرت اخيرا حكما بالسجن لبدعه
اشهر على اسرائيليين اودين بالاعتداء على
شاب عربي في الاحداث ذاتها لكن هنا يكمن
الفرق بين هويه المعتدي والمعتدى عليه
وبين السجان
والحالم بالحريه
لا تخفي الاجهزه الامنيه الاسرائيليه هو
جسمها من تكرار مواجهات ايار التي شملت
داخل الفلسطيني ولا يستبعد الفلسطينيون ان
يكون الهدف من وراء هذه الاحكام تخويف
الشبان والانتقام منهم بل فضه حاله من
الردع استعدادا لاي مواجهه مقبله
نجوان سمري الجزيره من امام سجن الجلمه
جنوب شرقي حيفا
حقا المنتخب المغربي تاهلا تاريخيا لربع
نهائي كاس العالم قطر 2022 بفوزه بركلات
الترجيح على نظيره الاسباني بثلاث ركلات
دون مقابل بعد انتهاء الوقتين الاصلي
والاضافي بالتعادل السلبي بين الفريقين
فقد اصبح المنتخب المغربي اول منتخب عربي
يحقق هذا الانجاز حمزه انقلنا الاجواء
اولا بشكل شخصي الف مبروك
الله يبارك فيك عبد القادر مبروك لنا
جميعا كلنا فخرون باننا كنا جزءا من هذا
الحدث التاريخي فخورون بتغطيته على شاشه
الجزيره وفخور انا شخصيا بان تابعت
المنتخب المغربي منذ اول مباراه وحتى هذا
التاهل التاريخي عرس كبير عبد القادر فرحه
كبيره عيد كبير بكل ارم مقاييس لك انت
تتخيل عبد القادر المشهد ونحن قادمون من
ستاد المدينه التعليميه في الطريق الى هنا
الى سوق واقف مشهد رائع للغايه يختزل شعور
الجماهير العربيه بهذا الانجاز الكبير همم
الاجواء في الطريق ذكرتنا بما شهدناه قبل
اثنين عشر عاما بعد فوز قطر بتنظيم كاس
العالم المنتخب المغربي با الا ان يضيف
جمالا على جمال وروناقا على رونق هذه
البطوله التنظيميه والعربيه بامتياز بان
نشاهد منتخب عربي الثمانيه الكبار نعم
الاحلام تتحول الى حقيقه اليوم منتخب عربي
بين الثمانيه الكبار في كاس العالم هنالك
الكثير ما يقال عبد القادر لكن دعني سريعا
ان سمحت الوقت اترك المجال لهذا الجمهور
الذي كان له فضل كبير في هذا الانجاز
جاؤوا من كل بقاع العالم منهم من استلف
منهم من جاء في ظروف انسانيه صعبه كي يكون
جزءا من هذا الحدث والحمد لله النتيجه
كانت رائعه انجاز تاريخ اليوم للمنتخب
المغربي
الحمد لله والشكر لله اول حاجه ثاني حاجه
نعيش حلم مونديال مغربي عربي افريقي
الاراضي القطريه الشقيقه فالحمد لله
الركراكي حنا معه
وكان حلموا معه وبغينا وبغينا ما نفيقوش
من هاد الحلم حتى القواصنا ان شاء الله في
المقابله النهائيه ولما لا فرق راجع حتى
واحد الرساله قويه لجميع الشعوب امن براسك
ان شاء الله والخيل قدام مدير النيه
واشتغل ان شاء الله ربي يوفقك الحمد لله
الحمد لله بحمد الله المنتخب الوطني
المغربي بين على واحد التاكسيك عالي والسر
الركراكي كتمناه انه يمشي على نفس الناجح
في المباريات القادمه ان شاء الله وكل شيء
العرب وكل شيء ليس افريقيا
نعم الله يبارك فيك
اجواء كبيره جدا الفرحه كبيره الاف من
المغاربه حجوا الى العاصمه الرباط كما
بقيه المدن المغربيه
للاحتفاء بهذا الانجاز الذي حققه المنتخب
المغربي لاول مره
تاهل الى دور ربع معنا بعض من الجمهور
المغربي لنعرف لهذه الفرحه
يا حمار
بالصوره تعبر عن نفسها
الصوره تعبر عن نفسها الاطفال الله الله
الاجواء الاستثنائيه في المغرب وارحب على
صادق تكلمنا عن المونديال عربي في قطر
مجموعه من الانجازات في التنظيم وغير ذلك
واليوم اي تتحقق انجاز بالنسبه للفرق
العربيه من خلال المنتخب المغربي بسم الله
الرحمن الرحيم
فمن 52 عاما كانت هي اول دوله افريقيه
تتاهل لكاس العالم عبر التصفيات وفي تلك
البطوله في المكسيك 1970 كانت اول دوله
افريقيه تحرز نقطه بالتعاد الخريف ومن 36
عاما كانت اول دوله افريقيه تعبر الى
الدور الثاني واول دوله افريقيا تتصدر
مجموعتها اليوم هي اول دوله افريقيه في
التاريخ تفوز بركلات الترجيح على فريق
اوروبيه افريقيا كانت امام الركلات
الترجيح حائط صد عالي جدا اليوم كان حائط
الصد معانا في ياسين بونو واصبح اول حارس
افريقي في التاريخ لا تهتز شباكه في ركلات
الترجيح ما حدث اليوم هو تاريخ بكل
المقاييس المباراه على الجانب الفني حدث
بها خدعه لم يتنبه لها كثيرون على الارجنت
فوز تونس على فرنسا وهذا اليوم في الدوري
المتقدم الكره على التقريب الانتصار اا
ايضا فوز السعوديه على الارجنتين وكذلك
تونس على فرنسا وكذلك هذا اليوم هذا
الانجاز التاريخي بالنسبه للمنتخب المغربي
مالفه انتباهي نفسيا وحتى قبل المباراه
الكثير كان يقول المغرب سينتصر اذا لا
تكلم عن مفاجاه او حسابات في اخر لحظه
ولكن نتكلم نفسيا عن منتخب عربي يدخل وفي
عزيمته الفوز
100% كره القدم تغيرت والفضل في نهضه اسيا
واوروبا وافريقيا على حساب اوروبا تعود
الى اوروبا الاحترام لان اوروبا هي التي
فتحت لنا الابواب ان ديت اوروبا اليوم تجد
اشرف حكيمي باريس سان جيرمان
في هذه المناسبه الساره شكرا جزيلا لك
طالبات الاندونيسيه من منبقها من السكان
في سفوح جبليه سيميرو شرقي جزيره جاوا
بمغادره قراهم الى منازل بديله وفرتها
الحكومه بسبب تجدد ثوران هناك ويشكل نشاط
بركان سيميرو اعلى درجات الخطر هذه الايام
حسب معايير الجيولوجيين الاندونيسيين
مع ساعات الصباح الاولى وانقشاع الغيوم
والطباب ينفذ بركان وسميره من جديد حوما
هو دخان مستخن منذرا للمواطنين في القرى
القريبه بمزيد من الاخطار
في برج مراقبه التابعي لمركز علوم
البراكين يراقب الخبراء على مدار الساعه
نشاط البركان واي هزات تنبؤ بمزيد من
الحمم
نشاط البركان ما زال بمستويات عاليه الى
حد مازلنا نشهد هبوب رياح ساخنه مع تدفق
الحمم من الفوهه
دمار خلفهم جراف الحطام البركاني باتجاه
الوديان اسفل جبل سيميرو ولولا الانذار
المبكر ونزوح سكان سريعا لاساقط مئات
القتل والجرحى كما حدث في ثوران البركان
العام الماضي
السيده جاريه وبعد انقضت عقود عمورها هنا
قررت الرحيل عن هذه المنطقه بعد ان منحت
منزلا بديلا
لم اكن ادري الى اين اذهب فهربت الى
المقبره كانت دخان كثيفا واظلمت السماء
وكانها مرت اريد الانتقال الى المساكن
الدائمه تلك
اني واعتباره علميا عند اعلى درجات الخطر
يجبر الاف السكان على ترك قراهم الى منازل
بديله وفرتها لهم الحكومه وهما حدث لقرا
اخرى مجاوره عند ثوران البركان العام
الماضي
العام الثالث على التوالي وفي نفس التوقيت
من شانه ونرى هنا الرمادا والحطام
البركاني الذي مازال ساخنه وقد سكب من
اعلى فواهه البركان في الشمال الغربي
باتجاه هذه السفوح في دفنت منازل
المواطنين وهو بقي حيا فقد عزم على الرحيل
الجزيره محافظه لما جان اقليم
نعود الى الحرب في اوكرانيا لا من زاويه
التطورات الميدانيه بالبنزاويه المقاوف
التي احيتها هذه الحرب بامكانيه
فما الذي حدث الرابع والعشرين بدات روسيا
حربا على اوكرانيا فجرت ازمه غير مسبوقه
منذ نهايه الحرب البارده يقول مساعد
الامين العام السابق لحلف شمال الاطلسي
كامل هي المره الاولى منذ بدايه العصر
نوويه
عربا تقليديه
بالمظله النوويه في عام 2002 2020 لم
تتردد قنوات تلفزيونيه روسيه في استحضار
احتمالات توجيه ضربه نوويه على باريس او
نيويورك بين بقاله دبلوماسيون روسي
يضغط على زر اذا اعتبر ان روسيا مهدد
بالاختفاء وفي ظل ضغوط على بوسكو لوح
الرئيس الروسي نفسه بورقه الاس النووي
قائلا انه مستعد لاستخدام كل الوسائل
المتاحه في ترسانته هذه الاجواء
والتهديدات والتلميحات دفعت الرئيس
الامريكي جوبايدن الى التحديث في تشييد
الاول اكتوبر الماضي من كارثه نوويه
محتمله
وامس فقط قال وزير الخارجيه الروسيه
لافروف ان الغربه يخاطر بصدام مباشر بين
القوه النوويه ستكون له عواقب وقيمه وفي
ظل هذه الاجواء يصبح السؤال ما هو مستقبل
معاهده منع انتشار الاسلحه النوويه الاداه
الحيويه للامني الدولي
يحكي شو مؤتمر مراجعه معاهده حظر الانتشار
النووي الذي عقدته الامم المتحده في اب
اغسطس المخاوف من الاضطرابات الجاريه في
الساحه الدوليه فقد منعت روسيا اعلانا
مشتركا للدول الموقعه وعددها 191 هو تحولا
تحول في موقف موسكو الذي كان تاريخيا
دائما لمعاهده حاضر الانتشار النووي وقبل
ايام قليله ارجو ان روسيا محادثات مع
الولايات المتحده حول معاهده نيو ستارت
وهي اخر معاهده رئيسيه لنزع السلاح بين
اكبر قوتين نووييتين كوريا الشماليه على
حد المخاوف فقد اعلنت في ايلول سبتمبر ان
وضعها الجديد بوصفها قوه النوويه هو امر
لا رجوع فيه لتغلق بذلك نهائيا الباب امام
اي مفاوضات بشان نزع سلاحها ثم توعدت
بيونغ واشنطن بيرد النووي في حاله وقوعه
هجوم على ارضها ختاما نتوقف مع مفهوم
اخلاقي واستراتيجي يشار له بالمحرمات
النوويه بشان عدم استخدام السلاح الذري
والذي تبلور بعد القصف الامريكي لهيروشيما
ونكزكي في عام 45 والسؤال هل لا يزال هذا
المفهوم قائما ام ان ما تغير فقط هو
الخطاب والسجاد ارحب بضيف من روما السيد
اليساندرو و ميلوتو ريزو النائب الامين
العام السابق لحلف شمال الاطلسي اهلا بك
ضيفي الكريم من روما ضد اللساندرو
هل نحن امام مؤشرات
حقيقيه لما يمكن ان يكون انزلاقا نحو
مواجهه نوويه ام ان هناك ربما
تصعيد او حرب نفسيه فقط
ان ذلك مجرد حرب نفسيه وهي حرب كلمات
لو توجهنا الى تصعيد وخاصه تصعيد نووي
فهذا يعني ان روسي ايضا ستعرض للضرب والذي
يكون هناك اي بلد
سالم وامن ولك فظيعه للجميع وبالتالي
يعتقن هذا امر لابد ان يتوقف واعتقد انه
يجب ان نبدا بالتخفيف التصعيد ما هو واضح
عليهم
روسيا واقراها غير قادران على الاتفاق
منهما وبالتالي لابدنا نحتاج الى الضغط
الدولي
للضغط على روسيا لكي تقبل وان ايضا لان هي
ايضا
السلام كما هو طيب لروسيا اذا ما وضعنا
التمني جانبا سيد اليساندرو على سبيل
المثال ما يجري في حول المحطه النوويه في
اوكرانيا تحديدا في زفروجيا
اليس ملابسه حقيقه حقيقه لما يمكن ان يكون
انزلاقا نحو فعل النووي
المشكله التي تخص المواقع
ويتذكرته هي مشكله موجوده وقائع من زمان
وان الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه فعلا
بان هذا امر خطر للجميع خطر على اوكرانيا
وقطر على روسيا وبالتالي فيهم روسيا
يلعبون بالنار حقيقي لانهم لانهم يعملون
ويستخدمون اسلحه في على في اماكن غريبه
هل الاتفاقات الحاليه الموجوده خاصه بين
واشنطن وموسكو هنا اتكلم عن اتفاقات صارت
وليسارت وصارت واحد غيرها هذه الاليات هل
هي كفيله بتجنيب العالم اي انزلاق نوويه
كما تعلمون عندما نتحدث عن معاهدات
وعن
الاتفاقات الدوليه وما الى ذلك
فهذا امر هو بذاته
ليس بالشيء المفيد لان هذه مشكله سياسيه
اولا قبل كل شيء المشكله ليست في المعاهده
النوويه المشكله
استخدام السلاح النووي لان هذا السلاح
سيكون مضرا
رهيبه لكل مجتمع الدولي والكل لذلك عالم
العربي واوروبا ولايه متحده ومن ايضا
روسيا
وبالتاليفهم يلعبون بالنار وقرر مره اخرى
هذا امر ينبغي ان تموت معنا الى التخفيف
التصعيد وان روسيا تستخدم كلمات سيئه جدا
للجميع
طيب ماذا عن الجانب الامريكي هذا ايضا
مازال يطور في رسالته النوويه
في عام 1994
من الجانب الامريكي هذه المره
امريكا وليس اوكرانيا
زينو
ليس هناك اي نشاطات نوويه
مثل هذه النشاطات
شكرا لك من روما لساندرو ميناتو ريزو نائب
الامين العام السابق لحلف شمال الاطلسي
كنت معانا من روما
منتصف الليل بتوقيت مكه المكرمه وهذا
موعدنا مع موجز لاهميه الانباء قبل
الانتقال الى جوله الرياضيه يوميات
المذيعه
قصف جيش التركي مواقع ما تعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه شمال شرقي سوريا وقال مصدر
تركي للجزيره ان انقر اعطت مهله للجانبين
الامريكي والروسي لاخراج قوه سوريا
الديمقراطيه من منبج وتل رفعت وعين العرب
والا فان عمليه عسكريه بريه ستكون بديلا
حتنيا
وقال الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان ان
بلاده مصممه على مكافحه الارهاب وانهائها
اينما وجد لمنع وصوله الى تركيا واوضح
اردوغان ان تركيا تملك القدره على تحقيق
انتصارات لا يتوقعها احد حسب تعبيره
اعلن الجيش الاوكراني ان القوات الروسيه
قصفت بقذائف المدفعيه الثلاثاء اكثر من 20
بلده في محيطبخ وافدين
وشرقيه اوكرانيا واضاف الجيش الاوكراني ان
قوته دمرت 20 وحده عتاد عسكري ونفذت 16
غار على تمركوزات القوات الروسيه
وانظيمتها الصاروخيه من جهتها اتهمت روسيا
اوكرانيا بتكثيف الهجمات بالمسيرات على
مطاراتهم داخل اراضيها
النائبه وزير الخارجيه الامريكي ان لدى
الولايات المتحده مخزونه اسلحه كافيه
للاستمرار في مساعده اوكرانيا واضافت شير
من خلال مشاركتها في ندوه بجامعه لويس في
ايطاليا ان اسرع طريق للسلام في اوكرانيا
هو ان تسحب روسيا كل قوتها رفعت شبكه
الجزيره الاعلاميه قضيه اغتيال زميله
شيرين ابو عاقله برصاصه قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي الى المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
تاتي بعد اجراء فريقها القانوني تحقيقا
كشف عن ادله جديده من جهته قال رئيس
الحكومه الاسرائيليه يا اير لذيذ انه لن
يسمح باستجواب اي جنديين اسرائيل
بدا نصل الى نصل الى ختام هذا الحصاد بكل
بلفاته السياسيه وكذلك الرياضيه شكرا لكم
على المتابعه والى اللقاء